you guys play pokemon unite yet
no i haven't
why not because i don't give a [ __ ]
about mothers oh true but you do give a
[ __ ] about pokemon yeah but there's uh i
don't know if you've heard but uh
there's about 100 other pokemon games
out there
that i could also play
but uh yeah i don't know like i saw like
a piece of news on twitter i don't know
how true this is but uh like i think it
was like
day two or day three that pokemon unite
came out and the league players were
like oh ho what's this and then they
invaded it and now apparently it's just
full of uh it's either you're versing
children who are eight years old or
you're versing league players
like that sounds like a terrible place
it just sounds like league 2.0 yeah so
i'm like no i like you pokemon but no
thank you yeah the games are either very
fun or not fun at all right you either
get like stomped or you don't as a as a
gamer and a moba player how did you find
it as a toxic gamer how do you feel
toxic playing games yeah as you talk to
gamer i i enjoyed it i didn't like the
fact that i couldn't racially slow
within 10 seconds of getting in the game
uh obviously that was very unfortunate
of course yeah there's no chat feature
there's actually voice chat apparently
is there apparently i don't know how you
could you if you get you have to you
have to hook up the mic through
nintendo's like [ __ ] way of doing it
yeah yeah i saw a voice chat option on
the game oh you know i have done that
through animal crossing actually oh and
it does not work so there is a chance
that if you're a league player you could
say something horrible to that
ten-year-old kid right
no i'm kidding obviously but i mean uh
yeah it's it's it's fine it's weird it
it it's it's pokemon but it definitely
feels like it's been developed not by
nintendo right like you can so has it
been developed by nintendo no it's by
tencent oh
of course of course
it has like i guess a monopoly on mobas
yeah um yeah it's like it's weird man
it's it's like when you haven't seen
that family member in like 10 years and
he comes back and he's really weird and
he's like yeah i'm the same guy right
you're like no no what is this you're
not the same person you're right right
it's like you know you you boot it up
there's there's gatcha there's loot
boxes oh that's you can buy gems it's
like oh my god this isn't pokemon what
is this nintendo micro transactioning
yeah nintendo's been real comfortable
with those micro transactions lately
they're getting real comfortable with
those loot boxes all right okay yeah i
mean like i haven't played pokemon unite
but i've seen like clips looked into it
and it just it it's so weird where did
this come from was this announced a
while ago because like the the whole
idea of like a pokemon moba is just like
how how did this happen when i think
pokemon i don't think league of legends
dota well i mean pokemon well people
thought of that about pokemon when
[ __ ] pokken came out right like
people are like wait what
pokemon yeah which is a great game now
right but i remember when it was first
announced people were like this looks
horrible this this just really i thought
it looked epic when it came out no i
thought it looked epic but i saw a lot
of people who are like that doesn't work
i don't know there's just something sad
there's something sad about seeing
a child's game by nintendo like this
that's just shoved full of these
egregious microtransactions yeah yeah
sure but i mean you know it's whatever
you can have a differing opinion on it i
don't really give a [ __ ] i don't know so
have you pulled for the gotcha yet uh
yeah tech tone i played with a friend of
ours and he was like he was home
he has a uh
whale that is pretty much his job yeah
and with without a loved one
yeah within five minutes he was like
spend 100 bucks just spend 100 bucks
just get everything just unlock
everything he's like and i'm like no i'm
not gonna do that and he's like i'll
give you a hundred bucks just spend it
right now and i was like what the [ __ ]
this man when it comes to gotcha this
man like loses all sense of money yeah
he has no
he has no way of holding back but i
respect it you know oh yeah of course
but i just didn't want it because i
could tell that i i i ended up spending
like 40 bucks on it and i was like i'm
not gonna play this again but i'm gonna
do it so i can play ranked right is it
free to play yeah okay
there's an excuse it can't there's no no
no
you said you spent 40 bucks which is
like free to play is the road to losing
items you can buy that'll uh boost your
stats in-game
so you can actually oh it's not it's
kind of like the way to win
the way it was explained to me and i the
way i understand it is that you know how
like league of legends used to have a
thing called runes yeah that
weren't pay to win they would give you
an edge but you could unlock them
through the game yeah but they give you
a noticeable advantage i'd say at times
um but would you like back in the day to
you to buy runes remember yeah would you
have described ruins as pay to win back
then it's kind of like that i mean it's
like
with the advantages that roon runes gave
back in the day you wouldn't be able to
take advantage of that small stat
increase unless you unless you're at
like the [ __ ] higher tier it's kind
of like it's truly optimized the game
just came out and no one no one's been
had the time to underground to get this
stuff so if you do just buy it you do
get an advantage it's not massive but
you get an advantage um i don't know how
big it is i mean from what i understand
it's not that much it is i mean
obviously any advantages should be a big
no-no in video games i think yeah yeah
but especially a children's game as well
it's like you know what's next [ __ ]
tetris with the microphone's actions in
it well i mean you know technically
speaking that's it's not the first
pokemon game with microtransactions
right i remember pokemon go back in the
day yeah and even then i felt like that
was like it's weird man yeah it's
strange i feel like nintendo they're
like well if another company develops it
it's not us
that is true
pokemon was also not them yeah but then
all but then nintendo also does weird
other microtransactions or uh brand
partnerships like they have [ __ ]
mercedes and mario kart 8. oh yeah yeah
mercedes
what was going on with that what how did
what what i thought it was like a joke
that someone at the dev team threw in
then i realized oh no it's an actual
brand like
how did this happen
what's going on and she baffles me i
mean i pick it every time i play mario
kart just because it's hilarious yeah it
looks so stupid baby mario in a mercedes
yeah just a full mercedes
i've never played mario kart aside this
is the first time i'm hearing it's like
a dead ass mercedes
and everything it's the car it's just a
mercedes car it's like three mercedes
cars and it's just it's just hilarious
to see baby
i don't know
it's just in the game in the game always
since release it's not even like an
unlockable it's just there by default
you can just pick a mercedes if you want
what yeah you didn't know this i thought
you guys were memeing no no
it's a straight up mercedes
what the [ __ ] is going on
like when you select the car as well it
literally says mercedes where does this
fit in the [ __ ] mario lore how how
did this happen well you know if you
know mario was like i'm sick of going
through all these levels let me just hop
in my mercedes
over all the enemies
you know at least yeah you know you're
getting into you know what i mean
nintendo i can't figure out what the
[ __ ] they're trying to do i don't know
what they're everything they're trying
to do everything man this is bizarre
yeah i mean i get it whatever i mean
good on them i guess man i just think i
get that grinder
man i just think unfortunately like uh
microtransactions just like kind of
creeping its way into the future of
gaming because it's just yeah it was
just sad because nintendo obviously was
the one company that for a long time was
like no
yeah yeah
but then now they're like yes yes yes
yes yeah
because like genji's come along and just
prove like how much [ __ ] money there
is to spend on anime wi-fi apparently
yeah it's like it's ridiculous because